guys we both know you were here for the
Biff us tonight the British Independent
Film Awards and you both work with
amazing filmmakers independently amazing
actors independently as well you've got
people like Idris Elba fantastic British
actor Christopher Eccleston you're
working with on Thor - John a hog before
Emma Watson you've got coming up as well
Colin Farrell I mean tell me a little
bit about what it's like to work with
those guys well I'm just so lucky to
work with amazing actors and directors
so I mean if for me the-the-the-the
making films acting is it's there's
nothing I can't do it on my own it's not
like I'm a writer or a musician the only
way you can make a film is if you
collaborate and it's all the the magic
is in the chemistry between you and so
I've just had huge fun with all of those
people that you've just mentioned and
and yeah we're in the thick of it I
thought - and hopefully making something
really exciting can we look forward to
some tussles with Thor and Christopher
Eccleston and a new ally a with
Christopher Eccleston the doctor himself
as he was
I couldn't possibly commit on either
side of that line but you know Loki's
the Norse god of mischief and therefore
capable of guile and deception and
manipulation and charm and provocation
so yeah he's got his fire crackers out
for sure a new course as you mentioned
he's a god of mischief how mischievous
would you say you are yourself and how
mischievous and a vampire are you could
you're working up in with Jim Jarmusch's
well aren't you well I'm I don't know
how do i how would you rate me on a
mischief scale I would say
out of ten mischief and eight and eight
that's pretty solid yeah it's better
than I was hoping for
I'd rate myself at about a four high
praise here its praise from the
praiseworthy as high praise indeed tell
us a little bit on the Jim Jarmusch
movie at all cuz of course you're
working with children now on you Tilda
Swinton we made it in the summer and you
know it's a film about love but that's
as much as I can tell you really it's
about a relationship and all the
tenderness and complexity of it and yeah
it really is that's what I mean that's
all I can say
Jim is editing at the moment he's having
a great time I got a text from the other
day saying he was really enjoying it
I hope the pictures are beautiful and
you know we just hope for the best we
had I had a really great time making
you